yes I'm here with our Soul Leader uh
another leader
wow congratulations well you beat
Alexander with the black pieces uh tell
us a little bit about well the game how
did you prepare somehow somehow I'm not
like I'm having very good school versus
Alexandra I don't know why I think it's
like a four and a half before this game
I was plus four so I drew only one game
I probably
she has probably worse score versus me
in her entire the one like all this
Royal fine and things I don't know like
I'm not comfortable like a opponent for
her and this game also proved even in
the beginning it was very shaky for me
yes I don't know she cannot like play
her best chess versus me I don't know
why
so Daniel Was preparing you
no of course like this was not
preparation yes he's helping me it's
very convenient I have her husband who
is a grand master very strong Daniel
Friedman I wanted to thank him for
preparing me for handling all my bad
mood sometimes
this is very nice but I found actually
one of his games in this variation so
let's have a oh really yes yes because
like I I Was preparing something
different and mostly I concentrated on
move Knight C3 and different line in
French defense Alexandra played like
your recent games this was Bishop E2
here so that's why I moved 93 was kind
of surprised even if I'm playing like
French defense in time my career I was
like was sleeping here I didn't know
what which line to use and what to do it
it is actually quite a rare line and
very solid one uh Bishop E2 is not
considered to be the best move here
because of because of what I did or
well you played well yes Bishop before
before it's a thematic idea here of
course so I like to know but the problem
was I was not like I I didn't know like
how to evaluate this position I'm like
my development is very bad I don't have
dark Square Bishop but on the other hand
I have wonderful C4 Square I'm trying to
exchange light square and Bishop and I
spend a lot of time because I was like
trying to evaluate this position it was
not like it was not obvious for me what
is evaluation here well it's perfectly
equal for the moment but I think that
you feel maybe these positions better oh
no no I did I didn't feel that I have
good position especially like with uh
like I was down on clock a lot and I
want to show nice tactics like couple
moves like after Rook B1
and some lines but you know like what is
what's interesting in some lines I was
even considering for hero like sacrifice
and queen because like all my pieces on
back Rank and just winners running
somewhere but of course maybe it's not
kinji one yes Kenji one here probably I
should take only two and continue doing
that I wanted to take off I'm not sure
this was I consider it at least two 1997
yes
well and then for the typical one yeah
it's 46 and yes and it's a different
game so I think that Alexandra lost the
thread of the game here after Queen C3
yes I think she blundered she just
realized that Bishop C2 is a thread
and then and here's very nice that I'm
very happy that I overlayed on this and
game Queen before
let's play no right here Queen before I
played group CH so as the spawn
sacrifice and uh after Queen this
three and I think I am better here well
you are winning here winning oh
so yes so this this end game will say
you're related this uh correct I played
many many games thanks uh who was like
training me a lot on this type of
position in one of U.S Championship we
had like many matches when it was
different system we play like similar
structure a lot yeah
yeah and so when you were completely
sure that you're winning I know that you
cannot win like I was when I tried
Queens okay so okay not winning that I'm
very close to win one actually wins
Turning Point yes yes because like okay
Bishop is not very good I have like pure
extra Pawn why shouldn't I be winning
here
and then I was like very nervous I was
like kind of shaky because yeah it was
not that I didn't like my position
because it was like very tense game a
lot of calculation before and finally
suddenly I am winning
so this was um well I think that was a
perfect a clean positional game uh
congratulations thank you so much Nazi
told us that you invited her to play uh
table thank you yes I played yesterday
table tennis thank you like guys who was
playing with me maybe I should have do
today repeat preparation yeah well we
are hoping to join you today okay yeah
our congratulations on a very very nice
just a very very quick question for you
I mean uh the sun is shining the birds
are chirping Everything Is Beautiful
uh everything is going your way imagine
Bella had made a draw
in that moment that you gave her you
wouldn't yeah
your your move between what would have
happened and now I'm playing chess for
for how many years for a lot I I had
ever seen in my life and moves like Rook
history as well so yes and I should
admit I have a lot of luck in this
tournament and I have feeling I should
have less points
our congratulations may the sun continue
to shine well done thank you yeah great
game today in the French defense very
much a very surprised that Arena has
fought herself